good afternoon it's great to be back in
Berlin one of my one of my favorite
cities so yeah I'm going to talk to you
today about test driven data analysis
which is a topic I've been talking about
for a little while now this is my first
sort of full PI data presentation on it
so I'm going to spend the first half
reviewing the fundamentals of what it's
about and then talk a bit about some of
the newer developments and where we're
trying to go with it
and my goal today is really to convince
you that if you do data analysis or data
science or anything that involves data
really you should be doing test-driven
data analysis so the idea for this comes
from software development where some of
you will be familiar with the idea of
test-driven development I think it's
certainly the most important development
in software engineering practice in the
30 years I've been doing it it's the
sort of common heart of all the agile
methodologies and the idea with
test-driven development is that if
you're going to write some codes for is
going to implement a division function
before you implement a single line of
that division function you first write
one or more tests that specify something
about what a correct answer would be so
you say you know when you divide 6 by 3
it should give you 2 or something like
that and there are frameworks that allow
you to run that test without having
written a single line of code and the
test will typically fail in fact to
really generate an error at that point
and then the idea is that you write code
to make tests pass possibly correct the
test if you had mistakes in your test as
well and you only write code when there
are failing tests so if you want to
extend the functionality you writes more
tests to specify that new functionality
if you get a bug you first of all write
tests that demonstrates what the correct
answer would be and then implement the
code and this turns out to be amazingly
powerful not in my view so much because
of the idea of writing the tests first
but because what what this results in is
that you have this big set of tests that
you can run
and the idea is typically that you run
these tests all the time like quite
literally having a continuous
integration system that is running them
in the background and reporting if they
stop working and this has various good
consequences but but the bottom line is
it makes code quality much better
particularly because if you have a lot
of tests that specify what the codes
supposed to be doing it gives you
freedom to rewrite that code without
worrying that you're breaking it whereas
one of the big problems with legacy
software typically is no one dares edit
the code because they know that they'll
just break it and if there's not
sufficiently good test coverage that's
difficult anyway that's that's the
motivation for test-driven data analysis
and so one of my good friends and
colleagues patrick said to me one day
you know we should do tests from data
analysis test-driven development and we
both instantly thought this was a great
idea to trouble us we had no idea what
test-driven data analysis men so we
spent the last few years trying to
figure that out and the trouble is data
analysis typically doesn't look as
organized as that software development
process I've drawn I don't know about
yours maybe yours does look organized
but what my normally looks like is
something like this you know you sort of
catch some data from someone it
typically doesn't have a data dictionary
it's typically very hard to understand
what it means and you spend ages trying
to eyeball the data trying to figure out
what on earth's going on santé checking
it you you start swearing at people
because clearly it was a maniac who put
the data together you've got duplicate
values the join keys don't work there
are missing values there are crazy
encoding x' there are numbers where they
should be strings and strings where they
should be numbers and all this kind of
stuff and it takes ages to get to the
point where you have any confidence in
what you're doing at all so how do you
how do you apply you know something like
this to process the world all familiar
with so the goal is to to take the take
this idea from test-driven development
of testing for software correctness and
having lots of tests and testing all the
time for software correctness with the
same idea for data analysis testing that
your data analysis is correct but adding
the extra things that make data analysis
more complex that is we have to worry
about the meaningful of the
meaningfulness of the analysis as well
as
correctness of the analysis we have to
worry about the correctness and validity
of the input data and we have to worry
about correctness of interpretation you
know it's not really good enough for us
to say well we produce the correct
result it's not it's not our 40 we
thought 99% meant it was 99% safe to go
whereas in fact it meant it was 99%
you're going to die if you go it kind of
really is our problem at least I think
it should be our problem so when I look
at we talk about analytical processes
and really buy an analytical process we
mean absolutely anything that starts
with data and produces some kind of a
result whether that result is itself a
data set or a report or a single number
or an insight or whatever but you know
but typically working with some
reasonable volume of data not just like
three numbers and typically these days
we find that there are two phases to the
thing there's development phase when you
try and figure out what the analysis is
going to be and you know that starts
with choosing the approach so this is
when you are doing all your eyeballing
and figuring out what algorithms you're
going to use and what packages you're
going to use and all the rest of it one
of things that can go wrong at that
stage is that we can fail to understand
the data or we can fail to understand
the problem domain or we can
misunderstand the applicability of
algorithms or methods or whatever and if
we do that then obviously we fail and we
produce in general and invalid analysis
and we call those errors of
interpretation it's something about our
interpretation of the data for the
problem that's gone wrong if we don't do
that then we have to do some kind of
implementation and obviously here a lot
of that would be in Python but you know
I'm really counting anything as
implementation even if it's just doing
something in Excel or using a package
there's still the process of taking your
data and making whatever software you're
using perform the analysis that you want
and if something goes wrong there we
call those errors into implementation
but of course they're just bugs they're
the the familiar easy ones and we only
get the answer right you know if we if
we don't make either of those kinds of
mistakes during that development phase
and once upon a time I think that's what
a lot of data analysis looked like but
certainly what we find is that these
days there's almost always an
operational phase as well where we have
to take that
whatever whatever that analytical
process we've developed is and put it
into production in some form either a
self learning system or a scoring system
or reporting system or whatever it
happens to be and that tends to be true
even if even if it was just a kind of
someone asks you to do something and
it'll be a one-off analysis almost
always to come back two weeks later and
say you know that thing you did could
you just just do it again on the updated
data or indeed it turns out the input
data was wrong could you do it on on the
correct data and so during that
operational phase we get a whole load of
extra opportunities for things to go
wrong because now we have to run that
analytical process that we've developed
and that's the opportunity to use the
software incorrectly even if it's
something as trivial as you know we get
the parameters in the wrong order or we
forget what file is or we think we're
putting in one file and we're actually
feeding in another file or something we
call those errors a process there can
also be perhaps the most worrying one
there can be a mismatch between the the
data that we use in operation and the
data that we used in development we call
those errors of applicability so it's
not it's not a bug it's not a fault that
when we develop a software we do it in
the context of one or more specific data
sets we have to do that otherwise we're
always trying to solve a completely
general problem and that doesn't work
but it is important that when we deploy
that thing that that analytical process
that we deploy it with broadly
comparable data data that would have
would have led us in the same direction
if we'd used it for development and if
that goes wrong that's very serious and
the final thing is when we get the
output we still have to interpret the
results and so there's another
opportunity for for an error of
interpretation there it's only if we get
through all those phases that we
actually get the right result in general
and when I say the right result I'm not
talking about whether the results off by
like a tenth of a percent or something
I'm talking about even the sign being
wrong or even you know completely
misunderstanding as I say taking off
when the system was telling you it's not
safe to take off lending to the wrong
people whatever it happens to be and
then of course because this operational
process we get to go around that loop
many times and make make the last three
mistakes as often as we want so if you
if you
take this at all seriously if your
process look anything there I look
exactly like this but if you buy that
this is something like what modern data
analysis looks like it's quite sobering
if you put some numbers on now I'm
extremely optimistic and extremely good
at this stuff I'm going to claim so I've
put very very optimistic numbers like
I'm going to say there's only a 20%
chance that I'm going to misunderstand
the data or the problem and there's only
a 30% chance I'm going to write
important bugs when I implement the
process and there's only a 10% chance
I'm going to forget how to use the
software when I run it and there's only
a 20% chance that I'm going to throw
completely the wrong kind of data at it
and there's only a 10% chance that I'm
going to miss understand the output
which all seem like pretty optimistic
Lamson you if you're all much better at
data analysis than me you know put your
90 or 95 your 99 percent in but with
these I think quite optimistic numbers
your chances of getting sort of broadly
the right arms for the first time
through are only 36% about one in three
and I'm not for a moment claiming that's
a real number these are made-up numbers
but they actually feel broadly congruent
with what we find it usually takes a
number of runs through before it starts
to work and every time you go through
there's at least the potential for that
to degrade again there's also the
potential for it to get better if you
find problems and notice them and fix
them during the process so so this is
the picture where we're working with and
Testim development as not just an
abstract thing but as a real thing as a
software library you can use and as a
set of things were developing has two
major components at the moment the idea
of reference tests and the idea of
automatic constraint discovery and
verification and I'll talk you through
what those means so very I'm going to
talk about these in more detail but very
briefly a reference test is for those of
you who know what they are a bit like a
system or integration tests in
test-driven development in other words
it tests broad really the way to think
about a reference test is it's capturing
what you did when you develop the
process including the data and the code
and checking that it still produces that
same answer later or a set of tests as a
set of things that you did when you
develop the code and checking that they
still work later and it's
we'll go through the details and the
second bit the automatic constraint
discover and verification is all about
getting the system to characterize data
that you're using at various stages for
you in the form of executable
constraints and then checking those
constraints against the data that you
run later this turned out to be quite
powerful ideas so we'll go through them
in more detail I should say there is an
open source library on github and pi PI
so you just pip install it or get clone
it if you want the source
it runs on Python two and three
it runs on basically all the Linux and
UNIX and Windows platforms it's MIT
licensed it's documented on there even
reference sheets and stuff so you're
welcome to use this stuff now we do have
commercial software as well and we tend
to develop the ideas and it's called
mirror and we tend to develop the ideas
in the context of that and then when
we've figured out how they're really
supposed to work we tend to copy them
into the the open source TDD a library
so some of what I'm going to show you is
not currently in this library but it
should all make its way into there we're
not deliberately holding anything back
we're just sort of not inflicting our
half half-baked stuff on you it's a
reference tests another connection here
which I didn't know about when we
started doing it is is reproducible
research which I imagine some of you
will be familiar with reproducible
research is a movement within the
academic community to get anyone who
publishes particularly scientific
research but any data based research
really to publish not only their paper
but their code and their data so that
other people can run it and learn from
it and check it and one of the important
parts about that is encapsulating it in
caps you know not just dumping the data
but not the code to pre-process it in
the form but dumping everything that you
need to to be able to use that code so
it's not directly about the computer
helping you be more likely to get your
analysis right it's about trusting other
researchers to look at it and say you
know this thing here on line 20 that's
nonsense or this input is producing this
output and that doesn't make sense
but this this idea of capturing so you
know when you develop your analytical
process you're going to do it in the
context of some data and you're going to
convince yourself that the
so right or at least good enough to use
or at least good enough that you didn't
abandon them and so the idea is that you
capture those things together you either
take all of your input data or at least
a sample of it you take your code you
freeze it or you put it together and
preferably wrap it up in a script so
that you can just type you know run or
whatever and the whole thing runs and
then you have you develop some kind of a
difference procedure for checking
whether the outputs what you expect so
if it's just a number it's supposed to
be 42 you check the answers 42 if it's
you know a great grid of numbers you
check that but it's the right grid of
numbers to whatever level of precision
is appropriate and what you might think
is that if you do that and you save the
code and you save the data and you run
it and then you run it a week later and
you run a month later and you run a year
later it's bound to work because
nothing's changed how could it possibly
possibly not work and the bad news is
that actually most of the time it
doesn't and you know there can be myriad
reasons for that
you upgraded your operating system you
upgraded your version of pandas the
operating system upgraded the operating
system your colleague upgraded the
operating system you installed a new
version of a package
you made a tiny little test that
couldn't possibly tweak to handle some
extra cases that couldn't possibly break
anything and yet you're helpful
colleague made a change to handle some
case you hadn't thought about yeah you
know and this is before you even move it
on to a different operating system a
different computer at different times
and even if none of those things are
changing your disk can get corrupted
time changes I mean you know you paste
data into Excel and what comes out
depends on the actual date on which you
do it it's you know hopefully your code
doesn't do that but but these are the
sorts of things that can cause this not
just to work so in the TDD a library
there is support for reference testing
and I'm going to rather foolishly try
and show you that and its support for
the same style of allowing you to run
tests even given the sorts of things
that you need with data analysis like
maybe the data isn't really exactly the
same maybe you've pasted a date into
there maybe there are precision issues
maybe there are all sort of things that
might be slightly different about the
data maybe using a graphing package and
the actual you know code exchange
there's a code
that it generates for the graph is is
different but the graph still looks the
same so it semantically there's lots of
support for helping with that kind of
thing so I'll show you a small example
of this so if you do have the library
you can I'm sorry if this is a bit small
I've made it as big as I can reasonably
you can say T DDA examples Network copy
a set of examples for you and if you go
into that there is a little thing that
generates a data frame it's incredibly
simple function it just generates a
thing with half a dozen columns 10 rows
mostly fixed fields but one random
number that obviously we don't want to
test as part of our thing because it's a
random number it's not going to be the
same from from run to run and there are
pre-canned examples of tests so there's
there's a test that checks that you get
the right data frame an fact there are
several tests of that and if I use the
unit test version and run it those of
you who've seen this sort of thing
before will see it's just running its 5
tests and they're all passing because
well examples supposed to pass right but
suppose we edit this code if I can find
my editor is the right one so this this
very simple code one of the things it
does is it prints out that last number
to three decimal places so let's just
change it so it only prints it out to
one and assumed that's what we now want
if we run that test again then now we
get failures because obviously we've
changed the output we're generating the
data frame to a different precision
three tests are failing which is a bit
confusing there's lots of output which
is a bit confusing but one of the things
it does is it gives you in here the
command that you need to use to actually
see what's changed which is helpful a
diff command I'm going to use open diff
the graphical one I suspect you can't
read that yeah okay so you have to take
my word for it that the stuff it's
highlighting on the left that's
different is the random numbers that are
supposed to be different and that's fine
and the stuff on the right is that
column that's now only
one decimal place instead of three
decimal places and so as part of our
diligent checking yes that really was
the bug fix or change that we wanted to
make and this is now the correct answer
I'm going to an assumed we did that with
the other two tests that failed as well
I'm now going to assert this is now the
correct answer and what the library lets
you do is if you now run the tests again
with exact same thing we're add a -
capital W on the end it will rewrite the
answers that it uses as references to
check against saying okay someone told
me these are now the right answers so
I'm going to copy those and if I now run
the tests again without that - W
they passed because obviously they're
reflecting my change so that was a bit
fast there's lots of lots of
documentation and all this stuff well
there's some documentation and all this
stuff if you want to play about with it
but this turns out to be really powerful
for spotting when things break that you
didn't realize I'm not going to go
through the detail but it's on the
slides so that's that okay constraint
generation and verification how am i
doing twenty minutes yeah okay so if we
go back to our analytical process but I
think every one of you agreed is exactly
what analytical processes look like one
of these we didn't really talk about was
what happens when you feed bad data into
this either during the development or V
the operational phase so if you feed bad
data in during the development process
and you don't recognize it the chances
are you're going to produce a bad
process because you know you produce the
right answers but from the wrong data or
answers you were happy with from the
wrong data so that's not good at all and
if you do it during the operational
phase the chances are you'll be passing
in data that you didn't really design
your process to deal with and therefore
bad things will probably happen so bad
data is a problem wherever it occurs in
the process and the idea with this
constraint stuff is that almost always
we're dealing with well one very common
example is in with our data analysis use
data tables you know a data frame or
similar as input or a set of data frames
it might be JSON or something like that
we're concentrating on tabular data at
the moment and there are many things
that we know should be true about that
data
and in principle we could write all
those things down but the thing is you
know we're lazy and we're human so even
if we did write it down we'd screw it up
because that's what we're like so the
big idea is to get the computers to do
their work for us instead so you know
here are some examples of the sorts
things I'm thinking about if you've got
an age it probably shouldn't be more
than a hundred and fifty if it's a human
and it's probably be an integer or at
least it should almost certainly be a
number and if you've got a customer ID
and a master table it probably shouldn't
have duplicates and if you've got a
credit card number it's probably have
sixteen digits and so on and so forth so
there are things that ought to be true
about fields and the values in
individual fields there are things that
ought to be true about datasets maybe
you have to have a particular field in a
data set even if it's you know it's
allowed to have some fields that come
and go maybe you've got constraints on
the number of records maybe some fields
ought to be tagged in a particular way
and there also might be relationships
between your fields like if you've got a
field called start day and another one
called end day it might be that the
start dates are supposed to be before
the end dates or at least not after the
end dates and stuff like that so all
these things we could write down but we
never do so and actually an example of
this which again I'll do live because
I'm stupid if I load up some sample data
show you it so this is prices so
Skyscanner you probably know it's an
online flight travel service but it
doesn't sell you flights it's a metal
meta search so it has Expedia and last
minute and all the airlines as partners
it just tries to show you the best price
so they're getting pricing data all over
the time they've got like a thousand
partners and they're integrated with a
thousand partners so they're getting
data in all the time and when you've got
a thousand integrations they break from
time to time you get bad data through so
here's an example of just some some
records that we get through i've
anonymized the sort of incriminating
stuff though i haven't changed any of
the numbers and eventually you get
ticket price and so you see some ticket
prices and card fees and card types and
stuff like that so let's just look at
what happens when we use this is mirror
and I'm going to generate constraints
and mirror but you'd get almost exactly
the same answer if you did it with the
TDD a library
pandas dataframe while the same pandas
dataframe our disco command which is
just short for discover it's the
discover command really and so if you do
that it goes through and does a lot of
fairly simple things and some slightly
more complex things so the first thing
it says is well this request ID field
that's a string so I'm going to turn
that into a constrain that it must be a
string field and I notice that the
lengths of all the strings in that field
are 36 I'm going to set the minimum
allowed length as 36 and maximum allowed
length is 36 and sign is only for
numeric values and it notices that there
are no nulls in there so it's going to
say knowles are not allowed in this
field and it doesn't say that duplicates
aren't allowed so that means that there
must have been duplicates in that field
because if there had been no duplicates
in that field it would have said this
field doesn't have duplicates and that's
an interesting example X you might think
the request ID ought to be unique and
the fact that it didn't do this is what
I call the Curious Incident the dog in
the night-time thing you have when you
look at a set of constraints that have
been generated you not only have to look
at the ones that are generated you have
to look at the ones that haven't been
generated as well to see whether
actually they should have been generated
and that's telling you something about a
problem with your data so those things
are all fairly straightforward and it
does the same sort of thing with numeric
fields and so forth the last two columns
are slightly more interesting the first
one is values allowed if it sees a a
string field that only has a small
number of values it will actually say
this looks categorical to me and I'm
going to say these are the only values
that are allowed and regular expressions
will we'll talk about in a minute that's
one of the new things but it also
generates regular expressions to
characterize the fields that you've
given it which is definitely more
sophisticated so it writes these are it
writes them as a set of constraints
I actually didn't do it there but I know
I have one kicking around that's very
similar to this so what these look like
is so they're json files and again you
get exactly the same thing out of our
software on our the open source library
so it has some metadata at the top and
then for each field it goes through
unless the set of constraints that it
knows how to interpret so here's the
regular expression it's generated for
the request ID which cuu ID
you might recognize so okay so let's
just see what happens if we so this was
done on a small sample of data like
15,000 records or something I'm going to
use a slightly bigger sample still only
300,000 records and I'm going to verify
against that and what verify does it
must have constraints on it what I
should have done is told it to verify
against that particular set of
constraints
so I'm surprised it's working but anyway
[Music]
yeah okay that's interesting it's great
but it's very playing in some sense is
probably more or less the same
constraints and what it's doing is it's
just going through and testing each of
the constraints against the fields and
saying does this pass or does this fail
and if not giving you some information
about how it fails in generating a whole
load of data that you can use so it's
getting there in a minute we'll see what
it didn't like what I didn't like is the
fact that I didn't actually verify
against the right data set right we'll
try it once more and then we'll move on
and you'll believe that it works really
because it does yeah this looks better
this looks better
let's just work through the slides
slightly so while it's doing that
hopefully it's going to get through oh
and there's an example of what it should
produce and probably has just produced
hasn't finished yet well this wasn't how
it was planned to happen okay
so while it's just finishing off an
important point to make is this is not
just for input data right so when you're
doing your data analysis you will
probably use multiple data sets for
input you're probably transform them in
various ways and you'll probably go
through a whole series of
transformations before you finally
present the thing to whatever your
central whatever your analytical
application is doing your you know your
model or whatever it happens to be and
then maybe you'll do small
transformations on the outputs before
actually dumping them into a report and
every time you have tabular data there's
an opportunity to generate a set of
constraints and to verify against that
during use let's see whether that has
done it yeah so here's here's an example
verification just with some different
data and you see there are set of
failures some of them unsurprising the
range of requests state so it generates
a constraint for date fields which don't
make very much sense one of the new
things is to generate relative date
constraints and sets and not say what's
the absolute range of dates but how are
they relative today or else some
reference date that you specify so those
have failed you'll see the minimum
maximum values there are some fantastic
minimum maximum values here the there's
a minimum card fee of minus 4.9 million
pounds which is the lowest credit card
fee I've ever come across
the bad news is there are some quite
high ticket prices as well in fact
there's 877 well you see the biggest
ones a lot better than the negative
smallest on but the totally the biggest
total price is 20 million pounds so
that's not very good either but you get
the idea
so moving on definitely moving on so yes
you should be generating a set of
constraints at
at every stage in your in your process
if you possibly can and verifying
outputs just as much as inputs so let's
talk briefly about Rex pi you probably
all know what regular expressions are
and you've probably all heard Jamie's
the Vince keys thing about you know some
people when confront with a problem
think I know I'll use regular
expressions now now they have two
problems as Jamie said twenty years ago
regular expressions are ways of
characterizing patterns and expressions
again I'm sure you all know this I'm not
going to belabor the point and they are
they're kind of our go-to way of
characterizing strings so if you have
not if you have free text strings but if
you have you know identifies various
sorts we have National Insurance numbers
and telephone numbers and zip codes and
IP addresses and stuff like that it
would be nice to make sure the data
conforms to whatever whatever patterns
there aren't we've got good examples of
those in principle we shouldn't have to
write the regular expression ourselves
we should be able to get a machine to do
that and that's what Rex PI does it's in
the TDA library though in the library at
the moment it doesn't generate
constraints I'm not sure why well we'll
make it do that so you know regular
expressions they have pros and cons well
they have a Pro anyway which is that
they're powerful and I suppose they're
ubiquitous but you know they're ugly
they're hard to write they're even
harder to read the even harder to debug
and they're pretty hard to escape as
well though if you don't know about it
you should use raw strings in Python
because they're fantastic for regular
expressions I mean you don't need as
many back slashes um so the idea is why
not let the computer do the work third
demonstration let's see if this one
works so there's an online version of
this as well but if we go to the right
place I have a file of postcodes
somewhere so here are some post codes
again apologies if they are too small to
read these are UK post codes pause views
of our UK post codes which have a
structure you can see so as a trivial
example if you say rec spy on those it
will generate what you will recognize as
exactly the right record expression I
mean it's it's it's a pretty easy one
but it's saying you get to get one or
two capital letters followed by one or
two digits followed by a space followed
by a digit followed by two capital
letters which is exactly the standard
pattern for excluding London post codes
and mysteries that's
the pattern for postcodes so that's what
Rex pies about and it's an entirely
heuristic thing it's not even using a
quality measure let alone optimizing
anything it's very much specialized for
identifies and structured data not for
you no human sentences and stuff like
that and it really prefers ascii to
Unicode at the moment I mean it uses
Unicode but it really prefers the
Unicode characters less than from 27 but
it's it's pretty fantastic it won't
always generate a single regular
expression it often generates a set and
though in principle we'd like it to get
better alternations and produce fewer
regular expressions in fact the fact
that it generates different ones for
different kinds of strings quite often
ends up being very useful because it
quite often turns out that it generates
one that correctly characterizes all the
good data and like 30 that characterize
each of the bad examples in your data so
although we'd like to we'd like to make
it smarter the fact that it's stupid is
actually quite quite helpful so I'll
finish by talking a little bit about
what we've got planned for TDD a the
things that are already implemented just
to whip through them and there are three
columns here with ticks so there's stuff
that we've tried stuff that is
implemented in our software and stuff
that's already in the TDA library but
everything ends up in the TDD a library
is not it's not we're holding it back so
you know we have reference tests we have
type constraints we have min and Max
constraints and for Strings those turn
into min and max length constraints we
specify sign separately as well because
even if you change the range of a
numeric value changing its sign is
rather more significant so we keep that
as a separate constraint we have nulls
constraints mostly saying that you can't
have nulls if if you can't or don't
duplicates constraint saying that you
don't have duplicates if you don't so
looking for a sort of key fields we have
categorical values constraints we have
these regular expressions constraints
and as I say that the code for
generating the regular expressions is in
the library it's just not wide up to
generate and check constraints yet we
have these time delta constraints I
mentioned so not just looking at the
absolute range of dates but the range of
days relative to when you run it or
relative
some date that you specify and we've
also been experiment we have in our
software we have stuff comparing you
know the sort of start date end type
date type thing I was thinking about
saying this pair of fields have become
satisfy constrain and we have foreign
key constraints checking that foreign
keys between tables work in in whatever
way they're supposed to things that
we're hoping to do and this really is
just about there and very briefly we
want to combine two different TDD a
files or automatically give you the
ability a bit like in the reference test
to say ok I've checked I've checked all
the violations in all the failures in
running this sort of constraints against
this data set and they're all ok so
write me a new file that combines the
old one a new one we can kind of do that
but not in the most sophisticated way
conditional constraint so if you fix
your data maybe there are constraints
that ought to be true for data after a
certain date but obviously aren't true
if you don't update the old data or
vice-versa we're interested in
characterizing incidents and doing root
cause analysis actually doing some
machine learning to figure out what's
going wrong when constraints fail all
sorts reporting could be improved
apparently Jason's a thing and we
probably ought to do something with that
and JSON schemas and that'll probably
pretty much do oh god there's more yeah
and all this stuff to distribution
shifts nearly nearly constraints are
really interesting a constraint that
isn't true but it's very nearly true so
you know the problem with that is it's
like almost no one defaults we'll just
say no Wonderfalls that wouldn't be a
good example of this but a good example
would be four out of your million
records you know have got strings when
everything else is actually an integer
or whatever constraints editor would be
nice constraints of various levels
alerting it all sorts of stuff I'm
running out of time so remember your ABC
always be checking go away and do test
driven data analysis and you can pick up
all the stuff I'm well that's me you can
get in touch there's a blog at TDD a
info coders at github there's a slack
channel if you mail or tweet at me or us
we'll do that there's a Twitter account
be careful those are zeros on the end of
Twitter handles not zeros that would be
an error of interpretation thank you for
your time I'd be very happy to take any
questions if I haven't talked
huh too long
[Applause]
so me quick
besides the stuff about regular
expressions in what way te da
tgd a help me if I'm already using Piper
if you're ready
[Music]
so I'll avoid the cheap shot of saying
nothing can help you if you're using PI
test the the TGA library so it works
with PI test as well as unit tests it's
fully tested the constraint stuff works
so yeah I don't know if I'm
misunderstanding aggression but there's
nothing to stop using all this and
indeed it's tested with PI tests as well
as unit tests
I suspect you meant something different
now okay nice talk thank you
when talk about reference testing and
you were like updating or capturing the
output of the no updated tests you know
I would do that locally because then
only I know that I fix that problem or
this is a known problem so it on the
continuous integration server then it
has go ahead mathematic like it's not
the question of orchestration how you
manage that yeah I mean the way that we
do that is we keep the reference tests
and get and so you know you update your
checked out copy and then you push it to
the same repository yeah but we're not
trying to solve the I mean there doesn't
seem any point in building another
distributed version control system
because we're not as clever as lineThe
so one last question time wait if you
smell here my microphone
yeah so yeah it looks pretty cool one
question I wonder is like for this
testing you need you need a perfectly
valid data set right in the beginning so
it has to be cleaned and maintained and
how do you make sure to so that that's
like a lot of manual work you have to
put it first right yeah so ideally you
would have completely clean data
generator constraints from and ideally
you'd check your constraints when you
generated them but in practice what you
find is more often you just generate the
constraints and if you can't be bothered
to look at them or there are problems
just put them in place stuff breaks the
next time you run it inevitably get some
stuff should break like right because it
puts a maximum number in and that number
was just a feature of your data set and
it shouldn't had a maximum at or it
should have been much bigger and that's
fine but if you if you then update your
constraints file over time those things
get better the danger is that you always
make everything looser doing that rather
than making it tighter the other thing
is a bit like any set of tests what you
have to do is from time to time you will
spot things that are wrong and you have
to go back and reflect those in your
constraints what you can do that helps
is you can be relatively conservative
about what data used to generate the
constraint so you can you know hand
check ten records or 100 records or
whatever and in many cases you can still
generate a pretty useful set of
constraints from that the other thing
you can do is you can generate
constraints of various to can generate
constraints every time and see how
they're changing it's in fact a diff
tool for that is another thing that
would be really nice to have hopefully
that helps a bit Thanks